coming up all the highlights from this
year's
grammys beyonce becomes the female
artist with the most grammy wins
ever and a teary-eyed taylor swift wins
the big award of the night
album of the year plus megan the
stallion makes history with her best new
artist win
beyonce bruno and body yada yada yada
yada welcome to et live's grammy's after
show
i'm daddy director and i'm cassie
delaura and i cannot and will not top
that but it was music daddy please stop
it was music's biggest night tonight at
the grammy awards and one
hell of a night for the ladies who swept
all four
of the major categories including taylor
swift who actually made history on top
of history
she's the first woman to win album of
the year three times and she had
such an amazing reaction to that as you
can tell there
and a congratulations goes to billy
eilish who took home a record of the
year
of course last year she swept the entire
major categories and in a very special
moment tonight she took that trophy
right there
and literally dedicated it to mega
stallion that's right meanwhile
she passed the torch for song of the
year to her who won song of the year for
her very powerful
and poignant song i can't breathe and
taking home the award for best new
artist which i called last week i should
have put a bet on this
meg the stallion making her the first
female rapper
to win this award in more than two
decades it was a lit grammys i'm not
gonna lie honestly
there's so much so good it was so good
and joining us to actually break it all
down is entertainment journalist and
host of more than that
miss gia peppers and eight-time grammy
award-winning artist yeah you heard that
right
eight times grammy award-winning artist
and the founder of the black owned
independent music and media enterprise
community culture mr phillip lawrence
thank you all so much for joining us i
know it's late on the east coast
and it has to be yeah it's all good
that's right guys let's get
right into it beginning with beyonce uh
she didn't perform
and she also didn't put out an album
this past year but she did show up and
show out there's the ivy park right
there
at the granby awards becoming the female
artist with the most
grammy wins ever before we get into you
guys let's take a look at her reaction
after she won as an artist i
i believe it's my job
and all of our jobs to reflect the times
blue
congratulations she won a grammy tonight
i'm so
proud of you no moment
what did it mean i i know the answer to
this question but tell the folks what it
meant to you
to see beyonce there first of all but
also to make some history
you know as the resident treasurer of
the beehive
we all screamed i think
uh joyous screams because one beyonce
has earned this
right she is the greatest entertainer of
our time
but she also has been in this game for
20
years right in 1996 she came out with no
no no and the girls of destiny's child
so for her to have this moment and to
just show that longevity that excellence
that
that black uh joy and black excellence
that she has
and exuded through black as king and the
gift and all the albums that she put out
that she's winning for
now it's just so great to see it's truly
a full circle moment
and a culmination of an already
incredible historic career
it's a big night for beyonce but an even
bigger night for the carter
family phillip little blue ivy became
the second youngest grammy award winner
now how about that unbelievable i got
little kids too and i'm trying to
imagine my little ones when you're
grammy
at her age yeah what an amazing thing
for the entire
family to share but you know i gotta
yeah
hey okay okay
i can't and danny where's your ivy park
i'm paying for mine
i'm paid for mine but you know what
mention it okay
next year uh listen not to mention
beyonce also won in some rap categories
this year with megan the stallion i do
have to say before we get into that
though phillip i love that you mentioned
the little ones because beyonce really
is the reason that so many of these
artists have pursued
their own music careers and i loved in
her speech she said you know she
highlighted and spotlighted
all of the black kings and queens that
are out there doing their thing this
year
and that includes meg the stallion who
had one
heck of a night of course she took home
the award for best new artist
also won best rap performance for savage
and
best rap song and she and beyonce made
history might i add by becoming the
first pair
of women to win the best rap performance
category of savage remix and they even
shared a very special moment together
during the speech take a look
i definitely want to say thank you to
beyonce waking meg's reaction
when her jaw dropped was all of us when
we saw uh jay
and beyonce for the first time in the
crowd i was like beyonce in the house
beyonce
in the house we're all waiting for it
would they make a surprise appearance
well thank god that they did but phillip
i wanted to ask you obviously with the
best new artist win
under meg's belt with you know
additional wins too what does this
mean for her as an artist and what we
can expect for the rest of her career
because
i feel like we've just begun when it
comes to meg the stallion
yeah i mean i think it means she has
arrived
right i mean this is her moment you know
as an artist you work so hard
so you know so many hours you put
everything you make all the sacrifices
and you think about meg you know she's
been freestyling and dropping mixtapes
and it all sort of culminates to this
moment and as an artist you don't ever
think about
the grammy stage and then as you sort of
inch yourself together and you have
these wins
it's huge for her and i think that she's
the kind of worker she works so hard
that this is only going to be the
stepping stone to greatness for her so
i'm so happy for her
go meg go back i love it and for her
i was going to say gia real quick and
for her to win with beyonce
her hometown hero they're both from
houston they get on a song together
and they're winning grammys i mean come
on that's what i that's what i was gonna
like add i think the moment where
beyonce chose to
stand next to her and let her have that
moment actually
let her be in the front of this historic
moment for her
was such a show of the support that she
has been to meg
we all know she lost her mother you know
recently
she's still grieving as a young girl in
this industry she needs big sisters and
beyonce and jay-z being her big brother
and signing her to roc nation
have been that support and so i know for
her how deep
that that must have felt where she
talked about how
she saw destiny's child in as a child
and was like i want to go hard like
beyonce
to be able to have that moment with b
must be in the absolute world and i'm so
happy for her i'm beaming for her
and i love that you brought up her
mother because she did have a moment in
her speech where
she gave a shout out to her late mother
and you know we all know as meg fans
that
her mother is one of the reasons why
she's continuing to do what she does
absolutely earn her college degree wants
to own an a
or open an assisted living moving
forward you know it was such a special
moment such a special night too because
she also performed and i got to tell you
meg's performance with cardi b was a
huge highlight for me tonight
you know i felt like i was missing at
the beginning of this award show
the grandness that is the grammy stage
and then
it looked like cardi and meg were like
give us the dimensions we're gonna build
a big bed
and fill it up with all these dancers
all these props i mean
uh let's start with you phillip what'd
you make of this performance
insane it was crazy i i
i think you're right i think that's what
we expect from the grammys right we
expect something big something to blow
us away
something we're not expecting to see and
they brought that you know
even with the costuming and the colors
they did their thing
they bodied it they bought it they got
through the second
my thing going into the grammy awards
was how explicit could they be
how are they going to get creative
because we've all seen the lyrics and
heard the lyrics to this song
but that's also what's so special about
this song too
is that they empower other women to
embrace their sexuality
and we saw that on stage yes we
did there were so many performances
i mean it was stacked with live music
they promised they were going to deliver
and they did
uh phillip let's start with you who was
your favorite performance of the night
you know i had many i had several
actually but i think
and and i'm not saying i have any bias
to this at all
but silk sonic come on baby boy
listen i gotta give it up to my boy you
know they
and one one of the most brilliant things
i think about bruno and i feel so
fortunate and lucky to have you know met
him
over a decade ago and have built a
career with him you know he's really one
of the most talented
brilliant amazing performers of our time
and you know when he
has his sights set on something you know
they've got this kind of 70
70s thing going he goes all out you know
i thought i was looking at heatwave and
the ojs and like they had the steps and
the
yeah i was a little mad that i wasn't
there
i was just about to ask you that like be
honest because you know you won grammys
with bruno you're performing on the
grammy stage with them did you have a
little fomo
a little bit i had a little promo i
ain't got a little piece of paper
you know but i let it slide because they
did so well and they sounded so good
and uh yeah i was so proud so proud next
year
yes there you go exactly yeah next year
yeah yeah
i love it you know who i was so proud of
tonight was country singer
mickey guyton can we all just give a
shout out to mickey for that incredible
performance of black like me you know
it's one thing to be
a female artist in country music but
it's another thing
to be a black female in country music
right now
and this performance taking the grammy
stage is
so impactful for so many reasons and it
shows
all the young black children out there
that they too
can a pursue a career in country and b
be on the grammy stage one day and
that's what i just loved about this
performance you know speaking of
inclusion i have to give a shout out to
bts performing at the grammys tonight
they were the only act
that brought the grammy states to seoul
they were the only ones not in los
angeles
and it was so amazing to see them
perform this is their second performance
but the first time
just doing a bts number they of course
uh collaborated and shared the stage
with a little
nilonas ex last year now i know the army
was real disappointed
they did not win that one grammy they
were nominated for but trust me look
they went from presenting
okay to performing to being nominated
for the first time
next is the win guys next is the win
okay yes next is the win step by step
and i wanted to add also you know silk
sonic i think
i was i saw a tweet a girl said i was
about to throw my bra at them
yes they give that same type of energy
that
like our mamas felt when the temptations
was there and
that that earth one and fire was able to
bring out of all of the people of the
70s and the early 80s and even now
they just have that good soulful energy
and i also have a given shout out to
little baby for bringing out tamika
mallory the founder
of until freedom um and killer mike
because
what an impactful year right we saw just
how much
black music impacted the storytelling
and the moments that we were seeing
in the media with the black lives matter
movement and so as beyonce said as
the artist's responsibility is to
reflect the times
for him to bring them out and say this
is exactly who we need to listen to
and the biggest night in music when
they're not even when tamika isn't an
artist
with such a major uh thank you moment of
gratitude in a
platform that we all should be paying
attention to so i'm excited
to see what happens with tamika from
here too but shout out to little baby
between little baby and dub baby and
mickey guyton i mean the grammys really
had
a number of impactful performances which
we're actually going to dive into later
on the show
but first let's get into some other big
winners of the night it was really
exciting to see harry styles take home
his first grammy award uh this is his
first time being nominated
and his first grammy win and not to
mention he is now the first member of
one direction
to walk over one of those little grammar
phones uh
he had a big night because he also
opened up the show too philip i mean do
you feel like there are some comparisons
here to say justin timberlake's
solo success you know when justin came
out with his debut solo it also
showed up at the grammys in a big way is
this a sign that we might be getting
solo harry a lot longer than
a 1d reunion
i hope so i'm a big fan of harry yeah i
think it's a special town i got
i got to tell you though as soon as he
walked downstairs i went to far-fetched
i said i got to give me one in both
okay you can't be the only one with a
bow play boy i need
i need one of those we knew he was going
to be the fastest i think
yes i think that this is just the
beginning for this kid i mean i had
an opportunity to be in the studio with
him once and he's just so humble
you know when he takes it all in he was
you know really listening to what we
were talking about and
had this you know sort of childlike
enthusiasm for creating music
i think the sky's the limit for him he's
got his fashion game is crazy her
brother was rocking leather
okay strong
someone else bringing the color to the
grammy awards tonight was
taylor swift and her floral number this
was her big return to the grammys after
five years she now you guys has 11
grammys she's almost up to 13 her lucky
number 13.
she won best album for folklore making
her the first
female artist in history to win album of
the year
three times i mean for a quarantine
project
this album gia are we surprised that
taylor took home
album of the year absolutely not
taylor swift is one of those icons that
at this point
uh when she puts something out it is
going to succeed she's she's
reached that level of success where
people love her so much and her music
and her sound
so much that when she put something out
her fans respond
her fans love her she can cover her own
music and still
win an incredible amount of awards and
love and support and so
to see her tonight return to the stage
and just to see her
one in her element right like i don't i
feel like this new
uh taylor swift is a lot less focused on
what people think she wants to be
comfortable she
she's confident she is ready to say what
she needs to say and she's gonna say it
beautifully through her music
and so i love this new taylor swift i'm
very much a fan
of her taking her career back and now we
get to see
all the the fruits of her rewards
and with all that being said i wonder if
evermore is going to follow suit
never never count taylor swift okay
never
never count her never count her out
there is still to come our guests are
sticking around and so you should too
next
we're recapping the night's best fashion
plus reunited harry styles and
lizzo celebrated backstage at the
grammys that and more viral moments from
the night
after this